[Music]
let's take a look at this clip ladies
and gentlemen from the zombie film take
a look captain agency star got a
situation on board
[Music]
did you hire Joe Jimmy was wrong
hey Dom if I get bit
[Applause]
[Music]
that was a lot of Maddy that look that
it was a lot of fun to do to fight to
shoot that gun and say payback is a
didn't see yourself doing more of
this acting now
Oh basically yes my only role my all a
dream to work with Kevin Hart
[Music]
[Applause]
what I love about what you guys have
done is you met years ago you talked
about this dream and you made it happen
here we are all these years later and
you made your zombie movie and you did
aspect that you had a premiere a
premiere that but press attended
everyone loves the movie and then you
fly out here to come on our show this is
pretty spectacular
yeah I've seen good Joe Armstrong here
that jet lag John Cena no there are
crazy people yeah it was cool meeting me
too
guys your favorite your favor
I'm told you're one of your favorite
things in the world is soda is that
right yeah okay what kind of sodas do
you like what kind of starter a short
story would you say all of them but diet
coke no a short story to it basically
bag and a diaper cocaine and to
coca-cola which is a drug so please with
caffeine yeah
and caffeine as ice is a drug where is
the illegal drug right so me magic
underwear I was harm like like bread
ball rock star solar root beer and crazy
I heard you guys I heard you guys really
love soda and you really love root beer
and that you love to do shots of root
beer so celebrate your film I brought
out thank you to your movie guys
all right now to see guys kind of one
more surprise for you I was told that
this is actually a request we said when
we invited Madi and Sam to be on the
show we said do they have any requests
thinking they might ask for maybe a
little soda in the dressing room or
something and they as you can see they
are not shy about asking for what they
want they said we demand a chocolate
fountain
so guys on the way out we're gonna bring
out your chocolate fountain is buddy
this is just for you guys
spring break zombie master is coming
soon to a theater near you follow Sam
and natty on Facebook or go to spring
break zombie Massacre Kombi hear about
upcoming screenings tsukemen Mattie's
new fell Jessie tsukemen
[Applause]
you